i watched another anime this uh this
this past weekend what did you watch i
watched jiu-jitsu tyson zero oh what's
the name
in cinemas how was it
it was
say it
say it god it was okay yeah
not
i thought it was good it was good it was
good it was it was
did you watch it in 4xd was 4xd whether
like spit on you and shake the chair and
stuff
no i didn't know that was the top should
i have that for you yeah
i
like the animation it was pretty uh i
don't know if watching demon slay has
just spoiled me in terms like shown in
animation
not with like the expectations that it
was going to be demon slayer move and
train level uh but i did come in knowing
that that was the last shown in anime
film that i had watched in theaters um
and i came out being just mildly amused
and just impressed by some animation
points but at the end of the day it was
like the most seven out of ten yeah i
was going to say it was the story good
it was okay
it was okay like okay
the people in the cinema next to me were
[ __ ] bowling their eyes oh yeah of
course i was like yeah you good
literally everyone in the cinemas when i
watched moogan train was just like just
light sobbing from every corner of the
room and i'm just like okay
this one next to me was like
full on
balling and i was like
are you okay
yeah cause like to to me moog and train
the thing that made mogan train special
for a shonen anime film was that it
actually felt canon you know it actually
felt like it had a real tangible effect
on the story whereas i know that jujutsu
is zero is technically canon because
it's technically supposed to be a
prequel but also it's like starring like
a main character that we hadn't seen
before
um and you know it is canon it's pretty
cool no it is it is
it is it is canon but it didn't feel
like anything i watched
in the movie had any effect to like
anything i watched in the tv series a
little bit a little bit very minimal
though like mainly the bad guy
mainly to do with the bad guy and then
i find i feel like i found out spoilers
from the people i was watching it with
and i was like oh okay so
i'm not i'm not going to tell you i'm
not gonna i'm not i'm not gonna spoil um
but it but it had like it didn't really
have that much of an effect it kind of
felt like a side story if anything
rather than actually having a proper
like i should care about all the things
going on and i think that's my problem
with a lot of shown in anime movies is
that there's
zero reason for me to care about
anything going on we spoke about this
like last time
literally every one piece movie well
yeah you know it's a good experience but
it is a bit odd because it's like it's
just i think it's been number one at the
box office in japan for 10 weeks now
yeah yeah of course yeah it's just like
i'm not i'm not just running printers
yeah yeah
after mugen train this is like every
industry is just like eagle vision on
cinemas now it's just like that's that's
where the money is yeah i mean it feels
like the the industry is definitely
gearing up more towards movies because
like yeah we were i mean the heavens
feel was like [ __ ] insane as well for
that like three-month process of like
all those yeah because like because like
when i got invited to see jiu-jitsu
caisson um i thought oh it's a bit late
isn't it it's is is it still gonna be in
cinemas uh because i missed out on
seeing dune because that was only in
cinemas for like a month and a half or
maybe even less in japanese cinemas but
like
with anime movies it just seems like it
just never goes out dude mugen train was
in cinemas for a year yeah like what a
year like how how is it a year later
people are still seeing it in cinemas
and they're still making money of this
[ __ ] i mean that's i guess that's why
it's like the top grossing anime movie
of all time but like my time scale for
how long movies are in cinemas are like
completely [ __ ] destroyed by anime
movies because they just never seem to
they never seem to go out they never
seem to they always seem to be in there
how long has jesus christ been in
cinemas for now
didn't it come out in it came out uh
christmas eve
oh [ __ ] so it's almost three months yeah
almost three months and it doesn't seem
like it's even close yeah to uh it
doesn't seem like it's either because
they have showings in four xd mxd or
whatever yeah they have uh 3d and they
have all the atmos and there's like in
this a [ __ ] ton going so yeah
like when i was stuck in uh hokkaido uh
because the airport has a cinema there i
was like oh maybe i'll see what's
playing um literally every
literally it was jiu-jitsu zero four
every single place they didn't have any
other stuff
was it was it just one screen was it
multiple screens uh
i believe it was two screens oh yeah
okay that makes sense yeah because in
like in a there's a ton of cinemas all
around tokyo that have like
20 plus screens or something ridiculous
yeah and you can watch there's tons of
foreign films so many of them and you
can watch jesus christ on seven of them
yeah i watched uh
operation mincemeat that's what it's
called the one with uh
colin firth
that doesn't sound like a real movie
never heard of that at all it's about
like a world war ii operation where they
like made a uh fake person but they got
a real dead body and gave it fake
documents and then washed it up in spain
was that like based off the true story
yeah it really happened oh wow really
cool really cool really really cool
story
basically like they wanted to make uh
germany think that the uk was going to
attack somewhere they weren't and so the
way they did it was by floating a body
to spain with fake documents on it and
then spain leaked it to germany and then
germany thought it was real stuff
because they made this person like look
so convincing that they were a real
person
it was a really cool story but the movie
was [ __ ]
oh okay is it is it a comedy it's a
drama but the problem i i guess
there wasn't [ __ ] it was a very i was
sick
five or six hours
no no it's like it's like
it's
focuses on like the personal drama
amongst the people who are doing the
operation yeah and so it's kind of like
human drama i
the thing is so interesting itself like
the whole story but obviously there's
not much known about it so they
obviously had to make it
yeah yeah and so it's kind of like
i mean colin firth's great he's always
great yeah but it was just kind of like
all right just me yeah well like like
going back to what you said about yeah
was [ __ ] like i was having this thought
the other day because like
i'm getting so bored of the word mid
right because like it just seems like i
like i tweeted out a tweet about like
[ __ ] demon slayer and the animation
and somehow that was like one of the
most toxic twitter tweets you tweeted
about demonstrate animation why would
you yeah yeah after what happened to me
guys why would i do that i just said
demon slayer had good animation about
that that was it
it was it was just like oh yeah demon
slayer i watch season two and i'm like
okay maybe it did deserve best animation
my [ __ ] god oh my like i had i
literally had to mute that thread that
thread compared to everything else going
on in the world that was the threat that
i had to mute in the past i'm like
gagging just thinking about that people
are clowns right like it does have the
best animation it's not even like a
contest people say there's other things
about no it's not is the story the best
no but like people are equating the fact
they don't like the show or they don't
like how much attention it's getting
yeah being like it doesn't deserve the
best animation listen it does it like
just flat out does yeah it does that
mean that it's it's a good show no no it
doesn't is it a mid shonen series like
story wise yes yes it is but it but but
the but
but the animation is [ __ ] dodgy
i'm not associating myself with that
listen i i [ __ ] love demon slayer
right
but it's the same reason why i watch
porn i like i like what's going on on
the screen i don't like the plot i like
that i love demons
is like the most like i love demons
you heard it here first i i i [ __ ] i
was so hyped watching it right yeah but
to sit here and be like it's a complex
storytelling no no
it's not it's a super simple shonen i i
think it's like what does mid mean to
you what does what does mid mean to you
what it means to me is that you can
watch it and there are many aspects of
it that you enjoy but there's also a lot
of aspects about it that just don't grip
you like there's a lot about it like
jesus
no
to me no because because i was i was
having this thinking i think the the
story is made yeah yeah you know as an
overall show it's good i i think the
story is you know slightly above me i
think it's a solid story it does
everything slightly above me
this is such a [ __ ] meaning
that's like saying like slightly above
[ __ ]
the train movie i'm gonna say it was
boring as [ __ ] i was bored out of my
mind watching that the whole way no okay
there was bits where it was good but
like the first first 60
the first like 70 of that movie i was
actually like resident sleeper bro i was
sleeping i i i agree with you
i think i think people forget that like
because everyone only thinks about the
last fight and like the last 30 minutes
of that movie because the the last 30
minutes were [ __ ] great they were
[ __ ] amazing uh the actual part when
they were on the train was to me pretty
pretty boring as [ __ ] it was it was the
part where they're like going to the
dreams i was just like snooze yeah yeah
yeah like literally snooze literally
snooze yeah i don't know it's yeah yeah
but like to me like i had i had this
realization that to me like something
[ __ ] like when i say oh yeah it was
pretty [ __ ] it was like it's a five out
of ten to me that's [ __ ] right whereas
you know if like i don't know why it's a
five out of ten [ __ ] to you i don't know
why that's to me that board is on like
average yeah where's when was the last
year about ten thing you've watched you
can tell you can tell yourself that five
out of ten in your head means that but
it doesn't five out of ten means right
because you're never gonna give anything
a one unless you really hate it right
you're not you never know three or four
see because in my head like i'm
operating on like the the my anime list
rating score right so when's the last
time you in your mind gave something a 5
out of 10 you could be watched read
whatever right okay because right
because seven out of ten means that you
didn't hate it but you are happy like
you had an experience that you were
happy with yeah did it blow you away no
five out of ten means that you're not
sure if you wasted your time
and that that's why it feels weird
giving things that you're like it's mid
a five out of ten because like i think a
one out of ten isn't even wasting your
time because that point at that point
it's an insult at that point you watch a
one out of ten you're like this is just
entertaining this is this is
so bad this is so like like you watch
exam you watch berserk 2016 you're like
okay this is obviously like [ __ ]
terrible but i'm having a good time
watching this just to [ __ ] on it but so
that's like to me it's like five is at
the middle where it's like all right if
you do nothing nothing good and nothing
bad you get a five right the most basic
to me to me a five out of ten when it
comes to anime to me a five out of ten
is like i finished watching it i feel
nothing about it and i forget about it
in a couple weeks you know five out of
five for me is like have i wasted my
time i'm not sure yeah no no 5 out of 10
to me is have i wasted my time yes this
this was a waste of time it was i i
didn't but it wasn't horrible
right yeah so what would you do
it's because huh what would you say four
is then
four is okay foreign is like i'm going
to forget about this but all i'm going
to remember about this show is that it
was a waste of my time no no because
here's how
here's how i think why when when we say
what the average when we say what the
middle of the ground what the average
score is most people will say seven even
though logically you think it's five
okay so if it's a five it's probably
like the lowest that you will ever
finish a show because to me if it's a
three or four i probably watch one or
two episodes and i didn't even finish it
because there's nothing in that to grab
my attention five is just like there was
enough for me to finish it and then i
regret finishing it because it was just
i understand that yeah because there was
nothing in there that made me want to
like remember it or left an impact on me
but the five out of tens are like in my
opinion they're the worst shows because
you just they're just thrown into this
pile of like oh yeah that existed what
would you give jiu-jitsu
out of ten i give it like a seven okay
because it's like because because no no
i wouldn't i wouldn't consider that it's
slightly it's okay
it's okay
see to me right when i hear it when you
say seven of me is like you were happy
and had fun watching it but the moment
it's over you don't feel compelled by
the show at all there's nothing that
makes it like really stick in your
memory it's like it's a good experience
and you don't regret it but nothing
after the fact makes you want to
actively think but that's that's the
thing it's like with jude kaisen like i
i finished it and it's like i had a you
know pretty good time watching it i was
like okay yeah this is this is good but
like when it was finished i was like am
i compelled to go read the manga or like
continue it on not exactly like to me my
hero academy is the exact same thing
where it's like season one it's like
yeah it was great yeah it was cool you
know i can see why people enjoyed it i
had a pretty good time with it am i
compelled to continue on with it
personally not
what would you give the did you watch
the demonstration yet have you watched
it yeah yeah what would you give it i'd
personally even though i said the story
is not the best i still think it's like
an eight or nine items i'd give it like
a solid bro it was hot it was it went
hard i would give it an 8.5 to nine um
and that's the the reason i say that
the demon slayer
it
counselor
amazing because i don't agree that the
story is mid because a lot of people say
the story of demon slayer is mid and to
me like
demon slayer's story it
it's as simple as it needs to be right
yeah i i feel like it's as simple as it
needs to be to make the rest of the good
parts shine the problem with demon slay
is like when you have an arc like move
and train and there are like fights that
aren't that don't stand out as much it's
like really
really apparent like just that the story
and the characters don't carry the show
as much but with
season two
because the because half the season was
just a [ __ ] full-on action fest
you're like you're like [ __ ] it oh this
is like an eight or nine out of ten i'm
like that's that's that's the point
where okay i don't really care about the
story that much if the action just
[ __ ] slaps this hard yeah
you know what i mean how dare you say
the enemy you know what i mean how dare
you say that
wow i don't think we've ever talked
about that on the podcast
yeah yeah i'm too afraid
because i've been on the other side
quite recently can you cancel about
talking about the animation
[Music]